Plants and animals live in the deserts.
Deserts are very dry.
Deserts can be very hot.
Plants and animals live in the oceans.
Ocean water is very salty.
Plants and animals live in the mountains.
Mountains are very tall and steep.
Plants and animals live in the plains.
Plains are very grassy and flat.
Plants and animals live in rivers.
River water is not salty.
Plants and animals live in rainforests.
Rainforests are very wet.
Plants and animals live in the tundra.
The tundra is very cold.
The tundra has no trees.
Plants and animals live all around the world.
Plants and animals live in the mountains.
Right. Tigers live in the mountains.
What else lives in the mountains?
Bears and rabbits also live in the mountains.
Do camels live in the mountains, too?
No. Camels live in the deserts.